vous devez faire une remarque préalable
et vous poser trois questions monsieur
le chef de cabinet remarques préalables
comme monsieur le secrétaire général de
l'elysée monsieur le directeur de
cabinet vous avez fait état de
l'autorisation qui vous a été donné par
le président de la république je veux
dire ici que cette autorisation n'a pas
d'objet il n'a pas d'effets en vertu du
texte que chacun commence à connaître
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en parler
beaucoup hier de l'article 6 de
l'ordonance du 17 novembre 1958 monsieur
sous brevet que vous connaissez
parfaitement qui prévoit que toute
personne tout citoyen qui est convoqué
par une commission d enquête
parlementaire doit déférer à la
convocation
c'est tout nul n'est au dessus des lois
à cet égard nous veut devons le dire
avec beaucoup de force
tout citoyen tout citoyenne doit venir
pourquoi parce que le parlement fait la
loi et contrôler l'exercice des pouvoirs
publics
et dans ce cadre comme l'a dit le
président philippe bas vous contribuez à
notre mission ma première question est
la suivante nous avons reçu monsieur
secrétaire général et monsieur le
directeur de cabinet
tous les deux nous ont dit ce que
philippe a appelé une sorte de vérité
officielle
je ne pense pas trahir ses mots à savoir
que monsieur benalla ne s'occuper que de
déplacement et n'exercer aucune mission
de police aucune
nous avons ici le permis de port d'armes
monsieur benalla ou jolie considérant
que monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police
nous avons de multiples témoignages
nous avons reçu 19 personnes nous avons
lu les trois interventions dans la
presse et dans les médias de monsieur
benalla une fois que cela a été fait
est-ce que sous serment
vous pouvez monsieur le chef de cabinet
confirmé qu'à aucun moment sous votre
autorité
monsieur benalla n'a exercé aucune
mission de police aucune soit en
substitution en complément aux
fonctionnaires et aux personnes chargées
de la police est alors même qu'il a
déclaré récemment dans le journal du
dimanche qu'il était en opposition avec
des conceptions du ministère de
l'intérieur de sites
pouvez vous nous confirmer qu'à aucun
moment à votre connaissance
monsieur benalla n'a exercé de près ou
de loin une mission relevant de la
police ciolos écoutez sur le votre
première intervention et la question de
l'autorisation
je ne vais pas me lever au dessus de ma
condition et pis le guet sur cette
question là
je vous ai indiqué avoir reçu
l'autorisation du président de la
république je les fais je m'étends pas
là dessus il ya sans doute des débats
constitutionnels sur ces questions là
ils me regardent peut en tous les cas à
mon niveau je vous prie de croire qu en
tous les cas moi je viens devant vous et
c'est pour faire oeuvre de transparence
sur le deuxième point
vous avez parlé de vérité officielle
il n'y a pas de vérité officielle il ya
une vérité lorsqu'on témoigne sous
serment et moi je peux vous assurer que
monsieur benalla n'a pas exercé de
missions de police
il se trouve que je sais un petit peu ce
que c'est qu'une mission de police
puisque je l'exercé 3 ans en cabinet du
directeur général de la police nationale
je veux là aussi rentrer un petit peu
dans le détail sur le excuser cette
parenthèse sur le rôle du chef de
cabinet chef de cabinet le chapus
j'espère a dit que c'était un chef
d'orchestre des questions d'organisation
matérielle
lorsqu'un le chef de cabinet se déplace
pour une mission préparatoire pour
organiser le déplacement du président de
la république
il a pour rôle de vérifier que la
sécurité du président de la république
est assurée de vérifier également que
les conditions d'ordre public sont
assurés sur le pour le déplacement du
président de la république je crois que
c'est normal chacun de nos concitoyens
souhaitent que dans tous lieux de notre
territoire le président de la république
soit en sécurité
il a pour ce faire
dans le panel des services qui se
déplace avec lui un service qui
s'appelle le j'espère qu'ils assurent la
sécurité rapprochée du président de la
république et qui est le conseiller du
chef de cabine elle dans ce rôle de chef
d'orchestre
il y également sur notre territoire des
préfets de la république qui ont des
compétences en matière d'ordre public
et puis il ya des policiers des
gendarmes lorsque j'ai
commencé ma carrière de sous préfet mon
premier préfet m'a dit françois xavier
lorsque vous êtes directeur de cabinet
que vous avez la responsabilité par
délégation d'un dispositif d'ordre
public
ne prenez pas la place des policiers des
gendarmes
votre relation avec le directeur de la
police avec le colonel de gendarmerie
c'est de lui donner des effets obtenir
le dire voilà ce qu'il ne doit pas
arriver et de le laisser faire son
oeuvre
le rôle d'un chef de cabinet dans une
mission préparatoire et lors d'un
déplacement c'est exactement la même
chose donc par délégation du chef de
cabinet alexandre bédat la chargée de
mission a pu demander des effets obtenir
sur un déplacement que ce soit au préfet
de police que ça soit un préfet de
département que ça soit un chef du
j'espère mais il n'a jamais pris la
place du policier ou du gendarme et en
ce sens il n'a pas exercé de missions de
police et je puis vous dire que si
j'avais constaté cela il se serait fait
là aussi fermement sermanni ce chef de
cabinet je vais redonner la parole à
jean pierre sueur mais voyez je vous
demande pas de vous mettre notre place
mais il ya des éléments contradictoires
et j'entends bien ce que vous dites et
j'entends aussi votre sincérité mais les
préfets de police quand il délivre un
permis de port d'armes
il le fait bien sur la base des
informations qui lui ont été données par
l'elysée et qu'est ce qu'il écrit le
relève un certain nombre de considérants
parmi lesquels je lis ceci considérant
que monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police dans le cadre de son
action de coordination de la sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr donc
peut-être que nous entendrons mal sur
les mots mais en tous les cas il a bien
fallu que l'élysée 10 au préfet de
police il a une mission de police sinon
il n'aurait pas eu de port d'armes
mais également on peut se dire pourquoi
a t'on demandé à trois reprises avant de
l'homme
nir un permis de port d'armes pour
monsieur benalla s'il n'a strictement
aucune fonction de sécurité
et je rappelle d'ailleurs que le métier
de monsieur bénalia avant d'entrer la
présidence de la république est
exclusivement un métier de sécurité
c'est sa spécialité c'est ce qu'il a
appris et c'est son expérience
professionnelle et mettez vous à la
place de nos concitoyens comme de
nous-mêmes nous ne nions une commission
d' enquête pour savoir les choses
clairement et il est né pour nous
difficile de comprendre la réalité des
choses quand nous sommes en présence de
contradictions et j'ai bien entendu ce
que vous avez dit est ce que vous avez
dit répond à une logique d'organisation
qui est tout à fait souhaitable mais
voyez c'est c'est eh voyez nous avons
des éléments qui sont sur notre table
monsieur loges alors je maintiens
évidemment mais mes propos je ne suis
pas le rédacteur de ce texte
réglementaire pris par le préfet de
police vous l'avez interrogé peut-être
rien
il faut peut-être le réinterroger mais
sur ce premier point crise et moi mais
qui a demandé le permis pour rien je je
je crois que patrick strzoda a été très
très clairs là dessus c'est lui qui a
été en contact avec la préfecture de
police sur ce sujet là pour quoi faire
non mais c'est lui qui a été en contact
avec la préfecture de police sur ce
sujet là il a demandé et je vous prie de
de reprendre les propos qu'il a tenus
devant cette commission
il a demandé à la préfecture de
de police d'analyser cette demande dans
les règles de droit non mon pour mon cas
personnel dont cas personnel cette
demande
cette demande de port d'armes dans le
cas d'espèce fondée sur des questions de
sécurité donc à différencier d'une une
protection personnelle n'a pas transité
par mes mains donc essais et je m'en
explique et c'est normal puisque les
questions de sécurité sont traitées
directement sous l'autorité du directeur
de cabinet donc je ne peux pas vous
répondre plus avant moi je ne sais ce
que je peux vous contenter de vous dire
et là aussi en restant à la place qui
est la mienne qui est celle de chef de
cabinet c'est l'émission que j'ai
conférer à monsieur benalla et je
voulais expliquer je crois en détail
faîtière forme et qu'il bénéficiait d'un
port d'armes
mais j'en ai été informé et vous ne
deviez mandat de prendre son arme ou
certaines missions et là aussi je vais
être très clair comme je crois vous le
dit le général lavernhe je n'ai jamais
vu monsieur ben alla avec son arme sur
une mission du président de la
république est en tous les cas pour les
missions qui sont les missions
officielles je ne l'aurais pas accepté
puisque la sécurité du président de la
république est assurée par ailleurs par
le j'espère et par les forces de police
et de gendarmerie mobilisées sous
l'autorité des préfets
je vous remercie monsieur jean pierre
sueur et non les détails on voit aussi
demandé pourquoi monsieur n'a bénéficié
d'une voiture de police
mais je voulais revenir sur un autre
point
il a été donc observateurs le 1er mai
est-ce qu'il vous avait informé
préalablement puisque vous êtes son
supérieur direct de son intention d'être
observateur
ce jour-là lui avez vous donné
l'autorisation ou pas chassons autre
chose ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure est important faut nous et
parler du 14 juillet de l'arrivée des
bleus
de l'entrée au panthéon de simone veil
les de son mari
j'ai été extrêmement peu frappé par le
fait que en dépit de ce que vous dites
monsieur mais ne l'a été au coeur des
événements en question
alors vous allez dire que ce n'est pas
vrai mais quand même vous n'avez pas eu
la réaction suivante quelqu'un qui
molestent des citoyens devant des crs
était policier qui fonctionne comme il
fonctionne se retrouvait une on ne sait
comment à une réunion de commandement le
soir qui dysfonctionnent aussi gravement
est ce que vous n'avez pas eu l'idée que
ce n'était quand même pas judicieux
qu'il continue à exercer des missions
des fonctions lors d'événements aussi
importants que ceux là et j'ai encore
une question
alors monsieur l'achat déjà en partie
répondu à cette question peut-être que
il pourra faire une réponse le président
mais synthétique et monsieur monsieur
sur pourrait poser ma dernière question
êtes vous pouvez vous dire devant la
commission que d'après les connaissances
que vous avez d'après ce que vous a dit
monsieur benalla pouvez vous assurer
qu'il n'a exercé aucune mission qui
aurait consisté à définir des
orientations stratégiques par rapport à
la sécurité du chef de l'état et à
l'organisation du gspr et du
commandement militaire
autrement dit pouvez vous certifier
qu'ils n'avaient pas un rôle extrêmement
important
beaucoup plus important que ce qui nous
a été dit dans la réflexion pour une
organisation de la sécurité à l'elysée
qu'ils soient en quelque sorte en
distance du ministère de l'intérieur
puisqu'il a dans la presse dit qu'il
avait noté l'opposition du min
ster de l'intérieur par rapport à cette
question comment analysez-vous cette
phrase alors monsieur l'ofs je vais
essayer de répondre à ces quatre
questions
d'abord sur la question du véhicule vous
avez utilisé le terme de voitures de
police ne sait pas une voiture de police
qui avait monsieur benalla c'est une
star véhicule de service
pas de fonction de service mais c'est
une voiture avec un pare soleil pour
déployer police
c'est pour ça que le nôtre rapporteur
vous pose la question et il faut être
précis
je crois qu'il faut être précis de
service sur lequel il le parquet police
je vais répondre si je suis désolé je
suis peut-être un peu laborieux dans mes
réponses mais chouette vraiment être pas
du tout répondu avec précision je vous
en prie monsieur loge à daisy alors donc
un véhicule de service pourquoi monsieur
benalla avait-il un véhicule de service
un peu étonné ça peut peut être choqué
parce que monsieur benalla il passait
ses journées et le début de ses nuits au
palais comme on le fait tous pour
organiser les déplacements du président
de la république
il n'était donc pas étonnant qu'on
puisse lui confier un véhicule pour se
rendre sur les lieux de ses missions et
le soir pour rentrer chez lui le matin
pour en revenir c'est précisément la
définition d'un véhicule de service
deuxièmement sur les moyens lumineux et
sur les avertisseurs sonores dont
étaient dotés le véhicule
il se trouve que l'ensemble du parc de
véhicules de l'elysée est doté de ses
moyens lumineux et sonore pour la simple
et bonne raison que ces véhicules
peuvent être intégrés dans des cortèges
et vous savez que quand le président de
la république circule encore tagil et
fait usage de ses moyens lumineux
généralement pas sonore d'ailleurs pour
des raisons de protection du président
de la république de bonne circulation du
cortège de sécurité des autres
automobilistes donc dire qu'il y a sur
ce véhicule des moyens est une chose
c'est pas forcément pour cela qu'ils
sont utilisés et s'ils le sont ils
doivent l'être dans des règles de
sécurité que que vous connaissez donc
oui à l'elysée il ya des véhicules avec
ce type de moyens il me semble que c'est
légal c'est pas la seule institution à
disposer de véhicules avec ce type de
moyens j'espère avoir répondu à la
première question sur ce que vous
appelez la voiture de police qui est
donc à un véhicule de service sur la
question d'une éventuelle autorisation
de ma part pour que qu'il soit
observateurs non il ne me l'a pas
demandé
alors là aussi ça peut vous étonner
puisque je suis son supérieur
hiérarchique direct
sauf que son supérieur hiérarchique
direct au moment où il visiblement à
cette proposition d'aller sur un
dispositif d'observation son supérieur
hiérarchique direct et en nouvelle
calédonie et il se trouve que nous avons
la pratique bonne bonne
il me semble
à la chefferie de cabinet tous les
matins de la semaine parfois même le
week end vers 7h45 d'aller faire le
point avec patrick strzoda directeur de
cabinet sur nos missions de la journée
et de la semaine et donc je veux dire à
patrick sera là bas voilà on prépare
t'elle visite la visite qui va avoir
lieu elles se passent bien et c'est donc
dans ces conditions là que monsieur
benalla demander l'autorisation
je n'y étais pas j'étais en nouvelle
calédonie et cette autorisation elle a
été régulièrement demandée
au directeur de cabinet voilà alors sur
ce point là également
j'aime pas du tout ça j'appelle ça de la
fiction administrative mais comment
aurais-je réagi si me l'avait demandé
vraisemblablement positivement l'y
autorisant puisque je vous ai dit que
dans nos missions de coordination
on avait à connaître des sujets d'ordre
public enfin de stratégie pas
d'application de l'ordre public
évidemment cette autorisation est
accompagné d'un d'une stricte limitation
au rôle d'observateur et est évidemment
juste espérer dans ce cas que monsieur
benalla soient accompagnés et qu'on le
limite à ces fonctions du jeu fut merci
accompagner et est limité à ces
fonctions d'observateurs ce qui
malheureusement n'a pas été le cas donc
je ne merci pour ce rappel c'est mathieu
donc je n'ai pas monsieur sueur a été
professeur de linguistique on peut s'en
remettre à lui sur toutes ces questions
et sur beaucoup d'autres
merci monsieur le chef de cabinet de
vous laissez surtout pas à theron je ne
me laisse pas interrompre je crois que
mes jeux
je crois que sur les les nouvelles
missions j'ai amplement répondu sur ce
que sur la question que vous posez de la
capacité de monsieur benalla de donner
des orientations stratégiques sur le
futur service en charge de la sécurité
de l'elysée là aussi je vais vous
peut-être énoncer des choses simples
mais qui sont celles que je vis il y a
actuellement deux services en charge de
ces querelles et de sécurité à l'elysée
le j'espère que vous connaissez
maintenant parfaitement le commandement
militaire
ils ont à leur tête deux généraux je ne
peux pas imaginer qu'on puisse penser
que deux jeunes héros laisse un chargé
de mission comme monsieur benalla
rentrer dans leur organisation interne
est commandée à leur place ce n'est
absolument pas le cas ça ne l'était pas
ils étaient les chefs des services les
organisateurs des services ils l'ont
toujours été
j'ai entendu dire également entendu
parler d'une milice privée à l'elysée
n'est absolument pas le cas
j'ai dit j'ai entendu parler mais je
sais mais je me permets de le dire
fortement
je passe mes journées avec les hommes et
les femmes valeureux et valeureuse du
j'espère à faire des missions
préparatoires
je les connais tous je connais tous les
chefs de mission du j'espère j'ai passé
trois ans à la dgpn
je n'ai vu que des policiers et des
gendarmes que des policiers et des
gendarmes qui exercent leur mission
conformément à leurs fonctions d'un
autre république et j'ai vu deux chefs
qui commandent leurs services alors sur
la réflexion de la direction de la
sécurité
qu'est ce qui motive cette réflexion
actuellement au sein de l'elysée
c'est d'ailleurs la cour des comptes a
pu dans ces différents rapports nous en
faire observation c'est la coexistence
de deux services
qui désolé mais là aussi je vais rentrer
dans des considérations d'intendance et
budgétaire qui utilisent quasiment les
mêmes moyens qui ont un commandement
différents et pour lesquels il faut
donner des synergies dans un objectif
d'économie c'est cela et rien de plus il
va de soi qu évidemment dans ce qui est
projeté le sécurité du président un
public est toujours exercé par des
policiers des gendarmes qui seront
toujours formé par le ministère de
l'intérieur est toujours en lien avec le
ministère de l'intérieur il n'y a jamais
eu aucun souhait de se soustraire à cela
mais je vous le dis comme une profonde
évidence et avec avec le coeur